hello freak [ __ ] a lot of guys have
broken their hands ground and pounded on
dudes because the [ __ ] skull is
stronger than the knuckle where the
reality is and one of the things about
boxing gloves as boxing those actually
help protect your hand and look how many
guys break their hands in boxing by
hitting go ahead yeah
Floyd Drake it's unbelievable but
there's a lot more hand damage and MMA
yeah it is I mean well there is a lot
though if you really stop and think
about how many guys break their hands
it's pretty extraordinary to work to the
point Boyd's hands were so bad it looked
like he was gonna have to retire one
yeah what did he end up doing he got
some rays yeah you got a crazy good
surgeon that little bitty hands yes we
got he's a kind of guy yeah anybody
who's ever met Floyd on TV everybody
looks bet he's tiny yeah but his uh he
FD he was using special gloves for a
while he's pulling his punches and just
just out boxing guys and pittypat him
you know who's breaking his hands like
crazy for a while right oh speaking of
that have you seen this kid we didn't
talk about that experiment and then work
too that's a lot of work it's
interesting to see the the attitude you
know that used to exist back then the
boxing gyms and now that people are
where we're seeing this evolution in
mixed martial arts where the beginning
we saw a lot of like gym wars like that
would be like a really normal occurrence
in gyms where guys would just beat the
[ __ ] out of each other you hear about
fighters getting knocked out in the gym
left and right left and right but now I
think people are starting to realize
like whoa whoa whoa whoa there's no
[ __ ] benefit in this like what's
going on here like we're gonna we're
looking at a gigantic multi Multi multi
million dollar business and this is how
we're treating our commodities and our
prospects where we're throwing them at
each other and let them blast each other
and do - getting punchy way before their
time we we both know gyms we're guys
they get [ __ ] way too quick and you go
well how's this guy like would this guy
had an iron changes three years ago I
was taking [ __ ] gym wars he's going
through gym wars on a regular basis yeah
that was shoot the box that was the deal
at shoot the box and Shogun himself said
like we realize you know after doing
that for awhile we can't do that anymore
well I I wasn't boxing to that when I
when I was involved in boxing some of
the best fights I ever saw
gentle yeah I know oh hell yeah one day
one day I saw a Livingstone bramble and
Roger Mayweather oh [ __ ] go at it I
had a [ __ ] gym in Vegas yeah another
time why one of the gyms because because
we all work together I worked with
Mayweather I worked with Nick one kick
Floyd when Floyd was first coming I mean
uh we all work together in these gyms
you know and uh one time there was this
dude he was a heavyweight his name is
Tracy and him and Roger Mayweather
[ __ ] got into it he was Tracy was a
young heavyweight 24 year old kid
heavyweight and Roger was [ __ ] 147
yeah in his 40s season logical I like
what you say [ __ ] just the dirt
the [ __ ] get into it low back and
forth ago [ __ ] there we go and I got in
the [ __ ] ring and start a fight man
yeah yeah they started [ __ ] fighting
and at the end of the round when the
bell went off Tracy tried to stop and
Roger [ __ ] lit him up and he goes no
rounds [ __ ]
no round so they just kept fighting
straight [ __ ] through until [ __ ]
Tracy quit oh my god Roger [ __ ]
whooped his ass and he [ __ ] quit in
40s yeah and then and then when he quit
Roger hit him another eight nine times
after he [ __ ] quit and he's basically
like don't have a [ __ ] mouth off to
me in this gym a 147 pounds 40 year old
yeah but Roger a black mamba yeah yeah
lot of people don't know Roger you know
a lot of people everybody knows Floyd
but Roger his uncle in his time he was a
bad [ __ ] he had a piston right
hand yeah he had a nasty jab and he
would [ __ ] slam that right hand in he
was a bad dude for many a year I've seen
some crazy [ __ ] happen in [ __ ] chant
boxing gyms man crazy [ __ ] okay yeah
that's incredible that's would you ever
hear about the Floyd Mayweather thing
where like when he was dealing with
those rap guys that came in and beat
when you guys got to whip people and
[ __ ] yeah what was that all about
again at one point you're lucky I
remember I wasn't there so I can't you
know this isn't like
[ __ ] eyewitness testimony but I I
heard about it too and what I heard was
the dude that was managing him at the
time was like a hardcore like real dude
and anything just walk into a gym I
heard he walked in the top ranked yeah
their gym pistol-whipping people and
[ __ ] pulling out guns with Floyd and
[ __ ] and kind of sets just whatever
their beef was got it straightened out
[Applause]
[Music]